♪
CHIP: When you're providing
things, you're doing things,
it's so much easier when
you're done with the work
to sit back and enjoy
than to spend
a whole day doing nothing.
♪
CAROL: Come to me,
fishy, fishy.
WADE: That sounded
new to me, too.
AGNES: No contact.
CHIP: Look at that.
I caught leaves.
(laughs)
Today, we're fishing down
in a place called O'lokatok.
My wife assures me
it's a good place.
As a kid, she used to
go down with her sister.
We eat a lot of fish, especially
with the decline of the caribou,
and we need some dog food,
and we need some people food.
This time of year, we have
two kinds of fish here.
There are sheefish
and there's the pike
that are out
to get the sheefish.
Well, I intend
to catch them both,
so, yeah, we'll see
how that goes.
WADE: Why do we have to do this?
CHIP: So we can eat the fish.
If you don't eat, you go hungry.
You know when
the caribou are gone
and the rabbits are gone,
ptarmigan are down.
WADE: Just fish.
CHIP: Fishing
is still pretty good.
Like hunting, do you like
to hunt for your family?
WADE: Yeah.
CHIP: You can fish
for your family.
You can get your anaa fish.
You can get your mom fish.
You can get
all your aunties fish.
You can get your uncle
some fish.
WADE: Hope I get one.
CHIP: I hope so, too.
AGNES: Chip and I decided
to take Wade Kelly out fishing.
Bringing the kid out
to spend the night camping
is really important
while he's young
so he'll want to
go back out there,
get more fish, and provide
for his family.
CHIP: Just 'cause the fish
aren't here right now
doesn't mean they
won't be here later,
so you can always
try these holes again.
Another thing,
we can go put holes
all the way along the river
if we felt like it.
AGNES: Could go a little bit
farther out still.
CHIP: Yeah. 'Cause I'm,
I've got about that much water
between the ice.
AGNES: Oh, I caught one!
CHIP: Whoa, whoa, sheefish!
AGNES: A little one.
CHIP: Sheefish, sheefish.
AGNES: Yay!
(Chip laughs)
Yes!
WADE: Whip it!
Are you gonna whip it?
AGNES: I got it already.
CHIP: See, Grandson.
Here, you trade me holes.
WADE: Lucky my anaa catch one.
We're gonna
have fish for dinner.
AGNES: Oh, I caught one!
WADE: She catch two of 'em!
CHIP: Yeah. Your anaa's
a good fisherwoman.
AGNES: (laughs)
No, I just was thinking--
oh, I got one!
CHIP: Again? Man!
Three different holes,
at that. Gee whiz!
AGNES: Every hole!
CHIP: Wow, just go over here
and bless mine, would ya?
Wow!
She is fishing
circles around us,
literally, look at this.
Right around us.
WADE: We got three fish now
because of my anaa.
CAROL: Got one.
WADE: What?
CHIP: Oh, a big one?
WADE: Just leave a fish for me.
AGNES: Oh, I caught one, too!
CAROL: Pull it!
Oh, man, you guys.
AGNES: I got a siulik!
CHIP: Oh, me, too!
Oh, me, too, look at that.
Oh, I got a pike, too.
Woo-hoo!
Wow, two siuliks at once.
CAROL: What are you guys doing?
(laughs)
WADE: I hope I get one.
AGNES: Grandson, the trick
is not to let your line loose.
Always keep it tight
like this. Look, tight.
And your fish won't get away.
CHIP: You'll learn, Grandson.
Ooh, I got one.
AGNES: Hey, hey!
WADE: A big one,
bigger than all of them.
AGNES: Hey, right on,
Carol, woo-hoo!
WADE: Oh, she finally got one.
Oh, I got one!
CHIP: Keep going,
Grandson, keep going.
CHIP: Oh, he got a fish stick!
(laughing) All right!
Grandson, come over here.
I'll make a new hole for me.
Come on, you can
come fish further,
where you can catch
something. Come on.
WADE: I thought I got one,
but it was just that stick.
AGNES: It's really important
to, um, make sure
we keep trying
until he catches a fish,
and that way he'll get that
feeling of, you know, providing,
and that's very important
that he gets that
if he wants to be a hunter
when he grows up.
WADE: I just want
to catch one fish!
♪